et maintenant
interview sans la bouche
[Musique]
jean-paul
interviews sont la bouche attention ne
dit rien vous êtes dans une soirée
claude berri vous vous salue en vous
appelant jean pierre rives vous êtes
obligé de sourire parce que c'est claude
berri vous souriez comme
alain dans la même soirée nicolas
sarkozy arrive vous salue vous parle
vous félicite un photographe arrive fait
qu'elle t'aide sur la photo jean-paul à
ce moment là une sublime gonzesses entre
ne regarde que vous vous êtes
inaccessible fait kate est inaccessible
mais pas trop
inaccessible mais pas trop mais pas trop
inaccessible inaccessible h une
excessive mais pas trop pas trop
discret
voilà
nicole kidman arrive dans cette soirée
où il ya claude berri déjà et nicolas
sarkozy mais c'est sa phase i et alors
est ce vous voient comme ça aille à
l'âne vous faites quoi vous
le font parce que c'est kidman excuses
voilà qui dit qu'est ce qui fait que ce
blaireau
jean-paul vous vous croisez quelqu'un de
visiblement important en fait vous
l'avez pas reconnu ces deux nouveaux
comics et alain delon fait quelle tête
l'américaine un genre vote jean-pierre
guérin le producteur de gilles escot
vous raconte vos débuts dans la série il
vous propose de revenir dans la série
julie lescaut à un million de francs
l'épisode pizza pizza pizza
millions de francs épisode
alors vous embarquez nicole kidman on
est lui dis moi je rencontre jean pierre
guérin julie lescaut final on marque
nicole kidman ses verrières en même
temps vous prenez votre voiture vous
allez prendre un dernier verre au costes
et là vous lui dites nicole
contrairement à ce que tout le monde
croit
je ne suis pas d'oran je suis américain
kader aoun je t'emmerde ça c'est pour
commencer
oui moi quand je fais l'américain je
suis un peu classe fait comme ça à
quelques pas
jean-paul
vous quittez le soir et à votre tour
j'en avais marre d'être avec sept
trophées sur marion gamme guerre
vous allez vous allez au cost ouais et
vous rencontrer alain chabat une colle
kidman qui sont en train de prendre un
dernier verre il fait l'américain
vous vous asseyez vous êtes là tous les
trois ou gréco et bien c'est le coup
ophélie winter arrive chez bonjour au
fil des mois comme chose dans les
cheveux
je peux pas parler et là elle me demande
pourquoi bah c'est un truc ardisson pas
dire bonjour normalement
il faut réinventer le lino lardy tube
abonnez vous il mettait un peu de bleu